within the first week of us being
together I was like you should quit your
thing and work with me even if this
doesn't work out this is employment this
is what I would pay and it'll be
whatever you're getting paid because I
know like if you can sell like we can
make a ton of money together so I was
not receptive at first and why is that
but we just met I mean and that was
where I was like I have this new idea
and I was like I'm gonna start this
thing called gym launch the next time
she came over like I had all the docs
and the bank accounts and everything
like it was all set up I was like well
I'm gonna go do this and I'll come back
and let you know how it goes and so I
called every night while I was doing
these launches and so I did three
launches and then I flew back as I took
out this fat stack of contracts I was
like can you just help me process all
these 45 minutes later we had processed
like 120 Grand or something like that I
knew what I was doing and so I was like
so like you want to do this thing with
me the first question she asked me was
is this legal